in den Analytics habe ich gelesen dass
es viele Menschen gibt die mich gar
nicht kennen und meine Videos zum
allerersten Mal schauen deswegen habe
ich mir überlegt dass ich einen
besonders guten Eindruck heute machen
möchte
[Musik]
mein Name ist Vanessa andere erwarten
eine andere Begrüßung hallo Leute hier
ist wieder eine
hallo Leute hier ist wieder eure Mal
waren und willkommen zu einem neuen
Adventskalender auspackt Video heute
packen wir den Kalender von Nina Schuber
aus
feminello von adventssam auf den
adventsson-kalender freue ich mich immer
das ganze Jahr über denn er ist einfach
wunderschön schaut euch diese liebevolle
Gestaltung an toll erinnert mich ein
bisschen an die Puzzle von Mirella bzw
von Villa Wunst es ist einfach ein Haus
im Design mit einer praktischen Box die
man danach für Geschenkverpackungen
benutzen kann zum Beispiel und bevor ich
jetzt die ganze Zeit adventsson sage
dieses Video ist doch irgendwie schon
wieder gesponsert weil adventssonne mir
diesen Kalender zugeschickt hat und
nicht nur den auch einen zweiten den ich
verlosen kann auf Instagram also schaut
einmal bei mir bei Instagram vorbei hier
findet ihr wie ich da heiße Überraschung
es ist der gleich Name und da könnt ihr
beim Gewinnspiel mitmachen viel Glück
warum hat Advents zu mir den
Adventskalender zugeschickt liegt
vielleicht daran dass ich schon mal Wein
musste als ich einen Advent zum
Adventskalender ausgepackt habe
aber daraus ist eine große Liebe
entstanden zu dem Verein ein Herz für
Rentner falls ihr das perfekte Promi
denn noch nicht gesehen habt da habe ich
auch hin gespendet und nie was von ihnen
gehört
so
aber was ist adventsson denn jetzt
eigentlich das ist ein nachhaltiger
startup-adventskalender mit Startups die
nachhaltig sind nein doch eins plus für
diese Beschreibung und neben den
Produkten die hier drin sind sind auch
Spenden drin sie sind liebevoll Hand
verpackt vom Team in sozialen
Partnerwerkstätten im Kölner Raum
preislich liegen wir hier bei 125 € und
ich glaube wir haben sogar eine E-Mail
von dem bekommen wo Sie uns die Preise
von den einzelnen Produkten
aufgeschrieben haben ah okay ich sag mal
so das können wir uns jetzt mal von
Anfang an sparen hier ist die Auflistung
der Preise und insgesamt ist da ein Wert
von 195 40 drin und ich glaube aber da
sind noch nicht mal Spenden drin aber
mal gucken ach die gibt's ja noch und
tip top da drauf also wirklich
Adventszeit ist so ein Kalender den habe
ich auch schon verschenkt innerhalb
meiner Familie weil ich einfach diesen
Gedanken so toll finde dass man viele
Produkte für wenig Geld bekommt
vergleichsweise wenig Geld aber
gleichzeitig da irgendwie noch ein
sozialer Charakter hinter steckt die
Spenden und einfach ja dieser Kalender
hat einfach einen guten Beigeschmack
wisst ihr was ich meine
so wir fangen jetzt mal an ne und das
ist einfach so ein Kalender das fühlt
sich an als ob das jemand von deiner
Familie oder Freundin oder so für Dich
verpackt hat also wenn man Single ist
und niemanden hat der einen
Adventskalender schenken kann
ja ne und falls ich auf Böde Gedanken
kommt ich habe wirklich keinen einzigen
Cent dafür bekommen um den jetzt
auszupacken
ja wir müssen uns hier so ein bisschen
durchwischen ne wir beginnen mit Türchen
Nummer eins und ich bin gespannt ob ich
nicht alle Produkte schon kenne weil
gefühlt sind in vielen das gleiche drin
aber vielleicht überrascht uns
adventsson das ist so wie Geschenke
auspacken okay
okay ich bin ich bin überrascht das muss
man auch sagen ne die machen das toll
dann hast du so ein Produkt du denkst
dir was ist das lies das Zettelchen was
es dazu gibt das ist so gut gemacht
köstliche Pralinen Selektion in
limitierter Blechdose das
Bernsteinzimmer cute guckt euch die
Verpackung es ist wirklich schön ich
weiß dass das bei mir nur rumfliegen
wird und ich wette dass ich da jemand
richtig drüber freuen wird wenn der das
zu Hause hat
ich mache das nicht auf ich würde gerne
wissen wie die Pralinen schmecken aber
mir ist das zu schade 11,95 € ja jetzt
muss man sich durchsuchen hier schon mal
die sechs und die neuen Klasse Nummer
zwei trumpet verpackt in Nummer 2
befindet sich ein Produkt aus Nürnberg
haltbarer mehr wegbecher okay das habe
ich wirklich noch nie gesehen oh
fühlt sich auch gerade hier ein bisschen
an wie Höhle der Löwen Produkte testen
ne oh das funktioniert
einwandfrei und dann trinkst du deinen
scheiß da aus und dann packst du das
schön ein und dann ist der klitzeklein
ich habe nur ich habe mehr also ich habe
Kaffeebecher to go die werden in
Deutschland hergestellt klimaneutral
aber dafür zahlt man dann auch 1995 ne
deutscher Preis Nummer 3 na klar kein
nachhaltiger startup-kalender ohne ein
festes Shampoo mit einer Schnur dran
ich glaube das löst ein Problem in der
Dusche weil du das dann so aufhängen
kannst und sonst weiß man nicht so
wirklich wohin damit aber ich frage mich
wenn man sich damit dann die Haare
wäscht und sowas dass das dann halt
irgendwann wahrscheinlich abfällt weil
es dann einfach der den Halt verliert
ich würde mir das auf jeden Fall an
meinen Tannenbaum hängen
ja der Geruch ist jetzt nicht mein
Favorite 9 Euro die verlosungsbox füllt
sich und wenn ihr den adventszone
Adventskalender nicht gewinnt könnt ihr
wahrscheinlich die Produkte in anderen
Kalendern gewöhnen ich mache jetzt ich
höre jetzt auf Werbung für meine
Verlosung zu machen
Nummer vier ist das was ich denke nee
ich habe beim Aufmachen gerade das
gesehen und dachte das ist von no
cosmetics aber da fragen wir uns doch
was ist das wirklich leckerer instant
Kaffee für unterwegs als wir von Blick
gehört haben waren wir erstmal skeptisch
schnell mussten wir dann aber
feststellen für einen richtig guten
Kaffee braucht es nicht viele Equipment
da nachhaltig und links das brauche
achso ich dachte das jetzt so einfach
Kaffee drin und Dings aber das sind so
einzelne Tüten drin die man dann mit
heißem Wasser unterwegs sich dann
auflösen kann kann tatsächlich praktisch
sein ich wüsste jetzt aber keine
Situation wo ich heißes Wasser habe aber
keinen Kaffee 4,99 Nummer 5
holt eure Taschentücher raus denn wir
haben einen Brief gekriegt wir haben
einen Brief gekriegt wir haben einen
Brief gekriegt ich frag mich nur von wem
ich präsentiere das wie eine
Nachrichtensprecherin
zwei Jahre Schule für sieben Kinder von
textilarbeiterin in Kambodscha schon mit
13 Jahren musste es ja Kong ihr zu Hause
verlassen und mit anderen Kindern ihres
Dorfes in die Hauptstadt Kambodschas
ziehen um dort als Näherin in einer
Textilfabrik zu arbeiten seitdem durfte
sie nicht mehr zur Schule gehen sondern
musste die Familie so finanziell
unterstützen im Dokumentarfilm Mode
macht Menschen erzählt sehr Kong die bis
heute in der fast fashion Industrie als
näheren tätig ist der Journalistin und
Aktivistin Helen Faris oh Helen Faris
kenne ich dass sie einfach nur hofft
dass ihr Sohn weiterhin zur Schule gehen
kann um eine Chance auf eine bessere
Zukunft zu bekommen und nicht in einer
Fabrik arbeiten zu müssen und stellt
e.v-stamp e.V haben deshalb das Projekt
Bella Chance ins Leben gerufen und
unterstützen mit Hilfe von NGO central
Kambodscha Familien die wegen fast
fashion Löwen unter dem Existenzminimum
in Armut leben ganz ganz toll so sieht
es aus hier könnt ihr einmal pausieren
deswegen ist dieser Kalender so
großartig ganz ehrlich Nummer
6 Nikolaus jetzt verstehe ich die Leute
die zum Beispiel Podcast machen und dann
über ein ernstes Thema reden und danach
aber ja irgendwie auch weiterreden
müssen irgendwie ist die Stimmung immer
alles wir machen jetzt weiter
Nachrichtensprecherin auch kommt so ein
schöner nachhaltiger Weihnachtsmann wäre
auch gut gewesen was ist das Knusper
Mandel Zimt gerne chocolate winterliche
rot-schokolade in Heim
kompostierbarer Folie letztendlich
wollen wir diese Welt ein wenig besser
zurücklassen als wir sie gefunden haben
und etwas Liebe und Glück verbreiten
Franziska Chief happiness Director
Schokolade als Wohltat für Körper Seele
und Planet das Ding ist ich öffne diese
Kalender immer mit so einer kritischen
hier oben Nase Edition ne und das mache
ich auch gerne ich ja so ich fühle mich
jetzt nicht schlecht dabei aber ich kann
immer diesen Kalender da fällt mir so
schwer zu sagen mal gucken aber wie sie
schmeckt
der hat einfach ein ganz anderen Weib
irgendwie wir einigen uns jetzt einfach
darauf ich präsentiere euch diesen
Kalender ich werde wahrscheinlich kein
schlechtes Wort finden und wir genießen
einfach die schöne Zeit zusammen okay
alles klar oh das ist Design das ist
plastikfreies Plastik ich weiß nicht wie
sie es machen immer wenn ich
kokosblütenzucker jetzt lese kann ich
nur ein paar mehr denken ich glaube das
ist die Mandel und knusprige Datteln
dass man das Gefühl hat dass sie sehr
zugriffig ist sie erinnert mich an diese
von deinem diese wenn man darauf rumkaut
und das sind so richtig krümlich Zug
riechen und wird so schmeckt die Nummer
7 ist schwer na da freue ich mich ja
ganz besonders drauf wir lieben es
Influenza Limes ihr liebt es aber und
make-herzen weihnachtlich duftende Kerze
aus sojawachs Leute halt stopp gutes
Wachs in der Kerze ist wirklich ein Game
changer letztes Jahr diesen EMP
Adventskalender in Kooperation mit
Moonshine und da hatten sie eine Kerze
drin mit gutem Wachs und die habe ich
dann angemacht und sie sind so ein Glas
und dann habe ich sie brennen lassen und
alles gut und dann ist mir gefallen dass
an diesem Glas überhaupt nichts
schwarzes rußmäßiges hängen geblieben
ist wenn ich eine Yankee Candle Anmache
also diese typische amerikanische dicke
glaskerze das ganze Glas so oben schwarz
ja tolles Jahr ich habe die Preise Ganze
gar nicht gesagt ne ach so doch 399 hat
die Schokolade gekostet und die Kerze
24,95 ja das ist halt echt stolzer Preis
für eine Kerze aber das sieht man auch
und das
ja riecht tatsächlich nicht so stark wie
ich dachte lange brennt sie 40 Stunden
also wenn ihr sie 40 Stunden lang an
habt könnt ihr ungefähr wissen dass sie
jede Stunde 50 Cent verbrannt werden
[Musik]
dafür ist Nummer 8 wieder ganz klein ich
glaube die hatten wir schon mal Zugang
da kommt es mir gleich hoch Ingwer
Kurkuma Kaugummi das bekommt man für
2,50 €, ich weiß nicht was ich von
Ingwer Kurkuma Kaugummi halten soll
nee mein Hirn hält das nicht aus Plastik
und aspartamfreies bioabbaubares
Kaugummi herkömmliche Kaugummis bestehen
zum Großteil aus Kunststoff und weiteren
Zutaten welche zum Beispiel auch für die
Herstellung von Plastikflaschen Kleber
und oder Autoreifen verwendet werden
alleine in Kopenhagen der Heimat von
True gun kleben rund 20 Millionen
Kaugummis auf den Straßen oder in der
Natur sie landen in den Kanälen der
Stadt von dort aus ins Meer und ins
Ökosystem stimmt Kaugummis müssten sich
ja eigentlich irgendwie biologisch
abbauen aber tun sie nicht die bleiben
einfach für 300 Jahre an der gleichen
Stelle kleben es schmeckt nach Ingwer
und Kurkuma aber nicht scharf nicht in
deine Fresse rein es kommt so dezent
daher von der anderen Straßenseite winkt
da Kurkuma und irgendwas hi
oh nein wir laufen nicht extra rüber
Geschmack der verwirrt mich es schmeckt
nicht aber schmeckt auch nicht
kommen wir zum wichtigsten Türchen des
ganzen Adventskalenders Türchen Nummer 9
ein Starter Kit für immer auffüllbares
Deo dürfen wir vorstellen dieser
fröhlich auffällige Blickfang ist ab
jetzt Dauergast in deinem Badezimmer im
Gegensatz zu herkömmlichen Deos kannst
du ihn nämlich wenn ein leer ist nach ca
7 Wochen mit einem neuen Refill
bestücken ah für 14 € mache ich auch
nicht auf Nummer 10 ist wieder eine
Spende meine Damen und Herren eine
Spende oh ein süßes Kind oh nein oh mein
Gott ist das ein süßes Kind bei mir
schießt langsam die Milch ein ne ich ähm
wenn ich Kinder angucke ich hätte es
nicht gedacht alle um mich rumbekommen
ja schon Kinder und ich war mir aber
sicher dass ich es noch überhaupt nicht
bereit bin aber wenn ich jetzt
mittlerweile Kinder sehe da kommen
andere Gefühle bei mir auf mhm mobile
Hilfe Madagaskar eV medizinisches
Vorsorgeprogramm für voraussichtlich 400
Kindern Grund besorgniserregende
Herztöne kam Jasper im april 2021 viel
zu früh durch den Kaiserschnitt zur Welt
die ersten Wochen verbrachte sie auf
unserer
Kinderintensivstation danach brachten
ihre Eltern sie weiterhin zu unseren
Untersuchungen die wir analog U1 bis U6
durchführen so wurde erkannt dass die
Kleinen in ihrem ersten Lebensjahr einen
hypo-hydrocephalus entwickelt hatte zum
Glück rechtzeitig sie konnte behandelt
werden und einen Schund Schand Schund
erhalten welcher sie vor dauerhaften
Hirnschäden schützt die adventsumspende
in Höhen von 10.000 Euro decken die
Kosten für unser Vorsorgeprogramm für
alle Kinder die 2023 in unserem
einziehen Einzugsgebiet geboren werden
voraussichtlich 400 Kinder Nummer 11 ich
sag mal so diese Firma kommt mir bekannt
vor die Backmischung 1,89 € und die gibt
es im Daniela Katzenberger ich glaube
Daniela Katzenberger wir befinden uns in
der halbzeitverbände Damen und Herren
wir sind beim Türchen Nummer
adventssonnen jungfeld wer produzierte
Socken in exklusiven adventsson Design
ihr wartet 2021 unfassbar begeistert von
den waldtiersocken und ich glaube ich
hatte die gestern sogar wieder an ja
jetzt gibt es hier noch mal das Design
ist mit einer friedensrebe 16 99 von
jungfeld produziert fern Portugal und
der Türkei
Nummer 13 Nahrungsergänzungsmittel mit
Matcha Grüntee Extra brami-extrakt
enthält Eisen koffeinhaltiges
Pflanzenextrakte B Vitamine die sind
Tabletten wie kommen die mir bekannt vor
natürliche Power Dragees für Dragees
drkaris
natürliche Power dracaris für
langanhaltende Energie richtige Power
things wovon ich mich ganz weit fern
halte und man bekommt sie für
6,23 € bitteschön und da ich ja jetzt
weiß dass es hier viele Menschen gibt
die diese Videos schauen ohne dass sie
mich vorher überhaupt mal gesehen haben
probiert mal aus wenn ihr sehr oft
gestresst und ihn Seite und sowas habt
dann auf Koffein zu verzichten mir hat
das sehr gut geholfen und ja ich bin
kein Arzt aber ich teile gerne meine
Erfahrung so gerne wie ich mit euch das
Türchen Nummer 14 Teile oh guck mal also
das hat doch gefehlt außerdem in einer
Box
köstliche Aufstrich aus Datteln Kakao
und Haselnüssen dattelfans aufgepasst
nur Datteln kein Zucker ein schöner
dattelauf für
7,95 € könnte das deins sein die Nummer
15 könnte wahrscheinlich noch mehr
wegbecher sein vielleicht ist hier ja
ein Gutschein für Primark drin
veganes aus Molchen Lippenpflege das hat
auch so ein sealing drauf das lasst sich
dran lippenpflegestick mit zitronigem
Duft 6,90 € könnte diese Lippenpflege
deine sein Nummer 16
heimische superfoods Moment Sat grünes
Superfood Pulver aus heimischen
Wildkräutern wusstest du dass
Brennesseln mehr Vitamin C enthalten als
eine Zitrone mehr Eiweiß als
Hülsenfrüchte und mehr Eisen als ein
Steak was Wildkräuter sind wahre
Kraftpakete und gleichzeitig auch ein
wertvolles Stück Naturschutz da sie
Lebensraum für Bienen und Vögel bieten
einen Esslöffel mit 200 ml warmen
Pflanzenmilch mischen für einen
stärkenden herbalatte ich hatte schon
mal so Gerstengraspulver bestellt und
das sieht genauso aus und riecht genauso
in herbal Latte mal gucken Brennessel
Löwenzahn und Giersch
ich heiße geschewski und das kommt vom
Namen Giersch okay das war ein Zeichen
das muss ich unbedingt ausprobieren 9,50
€ für ein Glas und nein dieses Kaugummi
schmeckt nicht ich muss jetzt gerade
rausnehmen mir ist gerade der Geschmack
irgendwie also am Anfang war es
interessant aber ich bin kein Kurkuma
Fan ich bin Ingwer Fan irgendwas Zitrone
Kaugummi hätte ich glaube ich mehr
gefeiert aber Kurkuma Ingwer Nummer 17
von den Wildkräutern geht es wieder zum
nächsten Brief oh nee oh ich habe Angst
in welche Richtung das geht seht ihr die
Gänse hier lasst Tiere leben e.V
lebenshof bei Berlin ein neuer Stall für
unsere Gänse und Enten gerade vor
Weihnachten ziehen immer viele Gänse bei
uns ein wir befreien sie aus Mastanlagen
oder vor schlachtenden Privatpersonen
oft haben die Tiere mit angesehen wie
ihre Freundinnen getötet wurden und sind
jahrelang schwer traumatisiert bei uns
bekommen sie Aufmerksamkeit Liebe und
den Raum sich zu erholen und neu zu
starten freie Tage vermissen wir nicht
den Tieren ein schönes artgerechtes
Leben ohne Angst zu schenken erfüllt uns
von ganzem so schön mit der
adventsumspende über 10.000 Euro können
wir einen dringend benötigen neuen und
größeren Stall für unsere Wasservögel
bauen schön Nummer 18 ich glaube das ist
Popcorn
Lieblingstee superkraut Design 10 von 10
schön was kostest du 8,99 €. ich bin
jetzt kein t-experte was sagen wir zu
dem Preis gerne in die Kommentare 13 in
die Kommentare und wir haben wieder ein
Glas und da haben wir mal wieder ich
glaube das habe ich auch erst in einem
Advent zum Adventskalender kennengelernt
Honig der kein Honig ist vegane Honig
Alternative aus Tapioka das will ich
noch nicht gehört 4,99 € na das ist doch
ein schnapperchen tolles Design schönes
Glas Nummer 20
plants a purple erfrischender
Gesichtsreiniger mit Aloe Vera erlebe
die angenehmen kühlenden Wirkstoff aus
Aloe jelly clansas morgens nach dem
Aufstehen
es ist refreshing und Clinton Aloe Vera
soll ja eigentlich gut für die Haut sein
aber ich habe mir letztens Aloe Vera Gel
für die Haut geholt und das ist so 99%
Aloe Vera also nur die Pflanze nur
dieses Schleim Zeug was da drin ist mir
drauf gemacht
19 Euro 90 das sind alles sehr hohe
Preise ne
ich ärger mich ich hätte den für ein
asmr-kanal aufmachen sollen alles ist so
perfekt zum rumtreppen
noch eine Backmischung Keksteig Mix in
Bioqualität zum rohrlöffeln ah oh okay
das ist cool Keksteig zum Löffel ah
thermisch behandeltes Weizenmehl ist
hier drin das heißt es wurde schon
erhitzt bzw
antibakteriell gemacht das ist save to
eat ist muss ich eigentlich auch nicht
ne dass man Weizenmehl nicht so roh
essen soll sondern thermisch behandelt
das ist eigentlich ganz geil für 5 € ist
ungefähr 500 g Keksteig
äh
okay ähm
Ackerbohnen Snack die Zutaten sind
Ackerbohnen und Steinsalz und Rapsöl
knusprig salziger Snack aus heimischen
Ackerbohnen was sind Ackerbohnen Brunch
Level 10 von 10 dieser Snack hatte uns
mit dem ersten bis das muss ich
probieren 2,79 €. das habe ich auch noch
nie in meinem Leben gesehen was ist das
und nicht wirklich ein Allergie dagegen
haben
ich liebe es in Polen gibt es ein
Gericht
da macht man diese Prinzessbohnen also
diese langen grünen Brechbohnen in weiß
sie kocht man und dann kommen sie auf
dem Teller und dann kommt so braune
Butter drauf das ist so Paniermehl mit
ein bisschen Butter in der Pfanne
gebraten und das wird so drüber gelegt
und das schmeckt ganz genauso das
einzige Problem ist dass das so knusprig
krümlich ist mit seiner Haut
das was im Hals stecken bleibt und man
die ganze Zeit husten muss der schmeckt
aber wie dieses polnische Gericht
ich komme nicht drauf klar das ist
ungelogen der leckerste salzige Snack
den ich jemals in dem Adventskalender
hatte da muss man aber auch den
Geschmack von Boden mögen also es
schmeckt wirklich richtig nach Bohne
aber so lecker davon bestelle ich mir
safe Sachen nach 23 das Wort letzte
tschüss
Produkt schneller einschlafen okay sorry
[Musik]
mit Melatonin und Vitamin B6 auch ein
Tipp zum schneller einschlafen das Handy
einfach nicht mehr in der Hand haben
glaubt mir das macht schon einen großen
Unterschied Fruchtgummis mit Melatonin
zur Verkürzung der eigenschaftszeit
falls du auch immer ein kleines bisschen
aufgeregt vor großen Tagen bist nasch
doch heute zwei sleep Dummies als
betthupfel sie enthalten keinen Zucker
dafür aber ein Milligramm des
schlafhormons Melatonin so dass du
schneller einschläfst und das ist so
krass dass man einfach so ein
Schlafhormon in so Gummibärchen
reinpacken kann das ist leider noch zu
früh am Tag ich hätte gerne gewusst wie
es schmeckt schlafen kann auch teuer
sein
12,90 € einfach besser einzuschlafen
wenn das hilft dann sind Leute natürlich
bereit diesen Preis zu zahlen aber da
ich kein Problem mit Einschlafen habe
wäre das für mich halt ja also da sehe
ich das nicht ich sehe mich jetzt nicht
Geld dafür ausgeben weil ich schlafen
kann ist es soweit
in der 24 du hattest eine tolle
Adventszeit eine tolle adventssonnt Zeit
weil du tolle Produkte kennengelernt
hast Spenden für tolle Projekte
abgegeben hast du hattest deine
Ackerbohnen und du fragst dich wie
konntest du jemals ohne deine
Ackerbohnen Leben und jetzt machst du
das 24 Türchen auf und nein ich sehe
eine alte Person das war der adventsson
nein Freunde alter Menschen e.V 10000 €
gegen Einsamkeit gerade an Weihnachten
spüren wir ganz deutlich wie sehr
menschliche Verbindung und mit Wärme
erfüll und genießen die gemeinsame Zeit
doch was ist mit denen die niemanden
mehr haben viele alte Menschen
vereinsamen und neue Leute kennenlernen
ist schwer vor allem wenn man nicht
mobil ist Inge erzählt ich hatte das
Gefühl die Wohnung erdrückt mich an
Weihnachten habe ich es früher nicht
ausgehalten und mich
[Musik]
Weihnachten habe ich es früher nicht
ausgehalten und mich ins Treppenhaus
gesetzt damit ich mal was anderes erlebe
also ich weiß nicht warum aber
mal ausgesetzt ich finde es einfach das
glaube ich das so schlimm für den
Menschen ist es ist so wenn man einsam
ist ich glaube
da also
Weihnachten treffen
das ist das das sorry aber das können
die doch nicht einfach so droppen unser
Verein möchte der Isolation alter
Menschen entgegenwirken wir vermitteln
und begleiten besuchspatenschaften mit
Freiwilligen aus den langfristigen
Kontakte entstehen das ganze Jahr über
zum quatschen Kaffee trinken Sorgen
teilen spazieren gehen mit Briefen
anrufen Ruf Konzerten und weiteren
kreativen Ideen versuchen wir auch über
die Treffen hinaus den Alltag unserer
Freundin zu erreichen dazu gehört nun
auch Inge und war so an Weihnachten
nicht allein wegen der gemeinsamen Feier
kann ich gar nicht genug danke sagen ich
nehme das Erlebte unintelligible
ich halte dich aus wegen der gemeinsamen
Feier kann ich gar nicht genug danke
sagen ich nehme das Erlebte mit nach
Hause kann mich freu Dich dran erinnern
und noch lange davon zehren wenn zum
Spenden setzen wir für die gemütlichen
Treffen ein die wir heute an Heiligabend
in Köln Hamburg und vielen weiteren
steht mit leckerem Essen und guten
Gesprächen ausrichten wenn ich selbst
kommen kann wird abgeholt und wieder
nach Hause gebracht Hauptsache heute
Abend
danke für deine Unterstützung und wir
wünschen Dir von ganzem Herzen
wunderbare Feiertage pS Wenn du jemanden
kennst oder selbst betroffen bist komm
gerne auf uns zu weil Freunde alter
Menschen ist jeder bekommt ich meine es
gibt auch andere Probleme wie Armut und
und wirklich Gewalt und wirklich
schlimme Dinge ne aber wenn es um
Einsamkeit geht und die Vorstellung dass
Leute irgendwo außer ältere irgendwo zu
Hause
oh Gott
ja toll schöner Verein hier könnt ihr
mal euch informieren ja mein Fazit von
diesem Kalender ja holt euch den das ist
lohnt sich Kristall
[Musik]